- Drugs is like what everybody turns to.
And then, like I said, they
call this the "City of Hope."
I remember one time somebody
took some spray paint
and knocked off the H and put a D there.
And made it to say the sign
that coming in saying the "City of Dope."
- [Interviewer] All right Matthew.
Matthew, where are you from originally?
Where were you born?
- I was born in Manchester, Kentucky.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both your parents growing up?
- I did until I was about four,
and then I have a
stepdad who actually used
to be married to my dad's sister.
So my mom left my dad,
and my aunt and her husband got split up,
which would be my uncle by marriage.
And my mom and my, you know,
used to be uncle by marriage,
or had been married for 20
some years now since '96.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
- So growing up in Clay County,
it was pretty, you know,
it was pretty boring childhood.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about Clay County.
- Clay County.
- [Interviewer] It's one
of the poorest counties
in the country.
- Absolutely.
They call it the "City of Hope,"
but really it's pretty hopeless here.
And you know, sometimes I
pray that for all the kids
around here, because there's just,
it is a really tough place to grow up.
There was no positive
role models, you know,
anywhere you go.
There's very few positive role models.
Let me put it that way, there's a couple.
But you know, it's just not a place
for that I feel kids should be.
- [Interviewer] Very few jobs.
- No jobs at all.
You know, the jobs that
are here are sold up.
You do have to go at least 45 minutes
to the towns around here,
and you might get lucky
and find a job.
But even those are rare.
And you know, if you get a
job there and messing up,
you don't have no options after that.
So, usually everybody will mess
up their first couple of jobs.
And so, yeah, it's pretty
rough on the work around here.
- [Interviewer] So you
got how far in school?
- I was in the seventh grade.
I failed the seventh grade four times.
And they automatically
moved me to the ninth grade.
And I did officially make
it to the 10th grade,
when that should have been my senior year.
'Cause they moved me up a few grades.
But I got expelled every
year since the seventh grade.
There wasn't one year that
I ever got to see the end
of a school year.
I got the full expulsion.
- [Interviewer] For what?
- Fighting, drugs.
A little bit of everything.
- [Interviewer] So you got
into drugs at what age?
- When I was a very young, you know.
The people around me, drugs is
real normal around kids here.
You know I remember school teachers
from down here coming to
buy drugs from my parents.
And I would go to school and
be there and see the teachers,
I know that they'd come to,
it was just real normal.
By the time I was five like
you can hand me any pill
that's out there and
make you say what's this,
and I could say that's a
Xanax, that's a Percocet,
that's a Lortab.
So I knew, you know, I
was raised around it.
- [Interviewer] At five years old?
- Yeah.
So, you know, it was.
- [Interviewer] And pills
were big then, right?
- Absolutely, there was no heroin
or nothing down here that was.
Oxycontin was the biggest thing.
And then the Percocet 30's,
and they absolutely destroyed this place.
And the churches tried to get together,
and places tried to
get together to make it
to fight against the drugs and stuff.
But even our government
like totally went downhill
in this town.
We had the mayor go to jail.
All kinds of stuff, you
know like, they buy votes.
You can get a vote for 20 bucks down here.
And there's people that all
these elected officials,
they hand out money.
And so say you're a runner to get votes.
They'll hand you a stack of money
and you go get everybody you can,
hey, I got 20 bucks,
jump in the car with me
and I'll take you and you vote
for who I want you to vote for.
So like, this whole town is twisted.
Like even the people
that are in authority,
just ain't altogether neither.
- [Interviewer] So where'd
your life go after that?
- So after, you know,
when I was 18 years old,
I went to jail the first
time, the big boy jail.
Adult jail here in Clay County
for something really stupid.
Got out in a couple hours.
And then shortly after that,
I went to jail for a felonious assault.
They said I broke somebody's legs.
And it was really a self-defense,
and I didn't touch the guy's legs.
He just fell and couldn't get
back up after he attacked me,
and I like kicked him off on me.
So my punishment for that was,
it was a class B felony,
and that's five to 10
years here in Kentucky.
So my punishment, they made a deal
with me that they would
drop it to a misdemeanor,
put me on unsupervised probation.
The terms of the probation
were to stay out of Clay
County for three years.
And they've actually, my
parents were at that time
we were already kicked out
for five years both of
them for trafficking.
So like, you know, that's
something they do a lot,
and just make people leave Clay County
when they get in trouble.
- [Interviewer] Rather
than putting in prison,
they just ship them out?
- Yup, yes sir.
But so then after that,
I go to Hamilton, Ohio,
and I did five years in prison down there
for robbing a bank.
You know, it all stems from drugs.
Like some of the people you
met today, when I was 12,
like I had people, adults
stick a needle in my arm
and shoot me up with cocaine,
when I was 12 years old.
I may have been 13.
I'm not quite sure the age but, you know,
people that were supposed
to be my role models stuck
needles in my arm when I was 13.
So that's, you know.
And I was in places where they cooked meth
for the first time at about 14 down here.
And that was huge down here, meth.
'Cause it was a lot
cheaper than the pills,
and it was a lot more affordable.
'Cause like I said,
there's poverty around,
nothing but poverty.
People are waiting at
their mailboxes every first
of the month waiting on a check.
Like if you got it on
the first and the third,
there's lines at the mailbox
yelling at each other,
hey, everybody just waiting for the check
because that's how everybody
survives down here.
So yeah.
- [Interviewer] What drugs are
most popular today down here?
- Most popular today is meth by far.
I have heard of heroin
being down here and.
But meth is like got this place destroyed.
Everybody's shooting up
meth, and it's crazy.
It went from OC 80's and
cocaine to meth and heroin.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- I am 29.
- [Interviewer] 29.
And you've done a little prison time?
- Yes sir.
I did five years.
- [Interviewer] Are you
working or have you worked?
- I own a business.
When I was 24.
You know my dad actually owned
a business here in Clay County.
They called him Jack the Tire Man.
He was also one of the elected
official I was referring to.
He owned the tire shop and he
was elected as the constable.
And shortly after he was elected
for the constable, he actually.
I went to prison and I talked to him,
and then three months
after I was in jail waiting
to go to prison, I got a
phone call that the feds
had got my dad, and he
was an elected official,
and he got 20 years
for selling one Lortab,
and he had a gun.
And they charged him career criminal
and they gave him 20 years
over one pill down here.
- [Interviewer] So you robbed a bank?
- Yes, I robbed a bank.
- [Interviewer] And how
many banks have you robbed?
- I got caught for one.
- [Interviewer] Good answer.
- It hasn't.
You know, like I did
make a deal that a lot
of stuff that I'd done,
in part of the deal I made
for five years, anything
that got brought up
after I did my time wouldn't be, you know,
they couldn't hold against me.
But the thing is, that's
only in the state of Ohio.
So, you know.
- [Interviewer] What
goes through your head
as you're planning to rob a bank?
What's the situation?
You're desperate for something, drugs?
- No, it was more of an adrenaline thing.
So I had been planning on
robbing a bank for six months.
I'd been looking at this
bank for six months.
And I actually knew a
couple of bank robbers
that got me into it.
You know, getaway driver, a guy
who's robbed multiple banks.
And you know, the getaway
driver and another guy my age
that was their first bank
they'd robbed with him.
And so I've known some bank
robbers and I watched them,
you know, and they
talked to me and told me
about the adrenaline you get
from it and how you can go in
and in 30 seconds come out
with all kinds of money.
So, and you know, it was a good story.
They also was talking
about how they took care
of their family after
they got out of there.
It wasn't really, they made it
so glorious to me, you know,
and I was a young kid.
And that's how I got into it.
So when I was planning
to rob this certain bank
for six months and had a great plan,
would've definitely, most
likely I would've got away
with it, can't say definitely.
But I had a great plan.
But then one night I was
partying with some girls,
and I had a bunch of money,
and they asked me how did
I keep money like that?
And I said, come with
me and I'll show you.
And you know, I said take me to this bank.
And they said, you know, what for?
And I said, I'm going
to withdraw some money.
And that was the first time I got caught,
but I'd actually did 20 Xanax
and drunk a half a
fifth of Captain Morgan.
And my plan went out the window.
I went in with no masks, no nothing.
Like I was so high on Xanax and drinking,
that everything I was
taught went out the window.
Everything I was taught
on how to not get caught robbing
a bank went out the window.
No face, no case, no double doors.
Watch the time limit.
You know, everything went out the window.
It was like I was watching out of my body
and watching from above like
on a video camera myself,
my body just reacted.
And I went in, leaned over the counter,
this is a robbery, don't make it a murder.
Give me all the hundreds and fifties.
- [Interviewer] How
much did they give you?
- Not enough.
It's kind of embarrassing to say.
They gave me five years to start with.
And $2,800.
So it was, like I said, I
wasn't in no shape to do it.
I did get away for a couple more weeks,
but like I said I had some girls with me,
and that was the dumbest
thing I ever could have done.
One of them I barely knew.
So I got told on.
I really, like I said, they knew my face,
but nobody where we was at in the place
we was at knew who I was.
So even if I had been all over the news,
and everybody see me,
there's a really good chance
I could have got away with it.
But I had some people
that were local to me,
that were local to the
community that was with me.
And one of them got scared
and they actually went
to the police and let them know who I was.
So, that's how I got caught.
I probably still could
have got away with it.
I was going for a week,
but then one of the girls
got so worried that if they
didn't step forward, you know,
that they would be charged
with the same thing
that I was charged with.
And, I found out a few days later,
one of the girls who I knew
better than the other one,
I knew her for a long time.
She said, hey, she tried to get me to go
to the police station and
tell on you last night.
And I was like, are you serious?
And I was still high for a
week after that, you know?
And I had walked to the person's house,
and I was going to knock on
her door, that wasn't a home.
And I remember going in, I had a BMW.
Then I go into their house,
and I'd steal everything
out of their house,
and throw it in my trunk
and drive down the road.
And next thing you know,
I'm about to leave town,
in Hamilton, Ohio, I'm
about to leave town.
And next thing you know, like
all these cops surrounding me,
somehow those people were
in the back of a cop car.
The girl and she had a boyfriend,
they was both in the back
of the cop car, pointed me
out at a Circle K in Hamilton.
And I had no clue how
they knew where I was at.
So, but that's what happened.
- [Interviewer] So you
moved to Ohio at one point?
- Yes, I moved to Ohio when I was told
to get out of Clay County.
- [Interviewer] So your arrest record
got you kicked out of town?
- Yup, and then after I got
kicked out of Clay County,
then in Hamilton, that's
when I started getting
in a lot of trouble.
Like I remember I stole a car one day.
And you know, that hill we just seen like,
I don't know if your audience can, like,
I'll try to paint a picture of it.
Or maybe you can flash a picture of it up,
I don't know if you do edit.
- [Interviewer] You can describe it.
- So my whole family lives up
on this hill on this holler.
And that's the way a lot of people are,
like families are in
bunches, in these hollers.
So up one side of the hill,
it's got a really steep
hill and there's a bank.
And on that bank, I had
stole this car in Hamilton,
shortly after I got kicked out,
I wasn't even supposed
to be in Clay County.
And I drove it up here.
And I sold it for $300 of meth.
And this was a really nice car.
And this is one of the
things prior to the robbery.
Like I said, my deal that
I made for my five years,
'cause I knew there was a lot more stuff
that could come back on me
that I'd done in Hamilton.
My lawyer made sure that
I would have immunity
for any crimes that I did
before I got caught for the robbery.
So that worked out for me.
- [Interviewer] Do you think your life
would be totally different if you grew up
in a different part of the country?
- You know, I think my life
would be totally different if.
Yeah, absolutely my
life would be different,
because it's just down here.
There's one thing,
there's drugs, you know.
There's church or drugs.
And I did the church thing
down here when I lived here.
You know, that's where you
get to see all your friends
when you're not at school
at church down here.
This is a huge place, but
everybody's so far away.
It's a small town,
everybody knows everybody,
but it's spread out really far.
And school's where you see your friends,
and church's where you see
your friends down here.
But then, you get that age,
and everything around
you is nothing but drugs,
even going to church doing drugs.
So there's the church here in Manchester,
it's the biggest church,
I would say the richest
church in Manchester.
It's right next to the courthouse,
that's where the lawyers and the judges
and elected officials all go.
And they have a youth pastor,
and a youth outreach program.
And the youth pastor,
there was always stories
about him touching kids
and stuff, you know?
He was, I believe he
was about 35 years old.
He never been married and
he's a teacher in Kentucky,
which is right next to Manchester.
And his life revolves around kids.
Well when I was in foster care down here
for my parents getting caught trafficking,
he chose like his victims.
He would choose problematic kids.
You know, I got suspended
from school every year
as I said before.
And he chose problematic kids to target.
And he asked me and a buddy
one night to stay one night
with him on a Saturday, and go
to church with him on Sunday.
And we both looked at
each other like what,
you want to the stay
night, we'll play ball.
So we played, he lives right
next door to the church.
We played ball in the outreach
center that whole night.
And about three o'clock in the morning,
we decided to go in and
was asleep on the couch.
And we laid down.
A few hours later,
my buddy's like Matt, Matt, Matt, wake up.
I wake up and he's like,
is anybody on the couch?
And I look at the couch
where he was asleep,
and he wasn't there no more.
And so then I look over at my buddy
and I remember we were
sleeping on a futon mattress
on the floor, and he was
right against the wall.
My buddy Billy was right against the wall.
And he had somehow like wiggled
his way between the wall and Billy,
and got a spot next to Billy.
And I still didn't think nothing
about it because, you know,
this is the guy who got
me believing in God,
and taught me about
God, and was in my life
when I was in foster care, you know.
A dark moment in my life.
And Billy got up and went
to sleep on the couch.
So then like I'm awake,
but I don't know nothing that went on yet.
Every like two minutes,
he's like scooting over closer to me.
Then all of a sudden his
head touches me right here,
and I'm awake, but I'm
acting like I'm asleep
and I don't know what to think.
Like I'd always heard those rumors,
and we never believed them.
- [Interviewer] And you're how old?
- I'm probably 15, 16.
So I'm old enough to know better.
Really I was old enough to know better
to let this go farther than what it did.
So his head's right here
and I'm thinking, huh?
Like maybe he's asleep.
Maybe he don't know, or
maybe this is his way
of showing me he loved me.
You know, I really trust this guy.
And then his head like two
minutes later, his head's here.
I'm thinking like, he's
gotta be asleep, you know?
I have no clue what he's doing right now,
it's gotta be something while he's asleep,
and he don't know what he's doing.
And then his head goes down.
And then, like I said,
I kept having these thoughts in my head.
Long story short, his head goes to here.
And even when his hand was right there,
I had this like doubt in my mind
that he was like this, you know?
Like I thought, you know, he
don't know his head is there.
And then I felt, I don't know
if the camera could see my lap,
but I felt this like squeeze.
And I was like, jumped up.
Like man, what the hell are you doing?
And he's like, act like he
was asleep and rolled over.
And Billy woke up the next
morning and left or drove
the church bus and we told
him like, what happened?
We told each other what
happened to each one of us.
And we decided since his
life revolved around kids
and he always had little
kids smaller than us
stay all night with him,
like every single night,
we decided that the best thing we could do
is go to the people at
school and tell them.
So we went to the assistant
principal, told him.
He said don't repeat that to nobody.
He said I'm going to get you
to see the real principal.
We go see who's also a
member of that church.
Me and Billy both tell him the story.
And he says, don't repeat that to nobody.
You know, don't say nothing to nobody.
And nothing ever came of it.
And that really, really messed
my like view of religion up.
It was a really dark moment.
Like I questioned everything about God.
The person who had me believing in God,
ended up being a pedophile,
you know, and nobody cared.
- [Interviewer] Did he
get caught eventually?
- He's still a school teacher
and he still runs the
outreach program here.
And I'm sure by now he's
got thousands of victims.
I know a bunch of his victims also.
Like I've talked to other, you know,
they didn't get believed just like
I didn't believe I'd heard the stories.
And I was like, oh man, you're crazy.
You know?
And then when it was my turn,
nobody believed me neither so.
You know, he's a respected
member of the community,
but he is a pedophile, and
he uses his job and his spot
at the church to pick out targets.
And like I said, he picks
the most vulnerable people
he can find, the problematic kids
that he can lie his way out,
nobody's going to believe them.
You know, that has issues at home.
And I'm sure he's even
had a couple of the kids
that he's messed up for life, you know.
Went a lot further with them
that didn't know better.
'Cause I remember even a little kid
that was, he was my foster brother.
I had to help him get
on the bus every day.
Him and his little sister,
they're like five and seven.
Even a little seven year old boy used
to spend the night with him all the time.
I'm old enough to know
that a man's not supposed
to grab, the youth pastor's not supposed
to grab my penis while I'm asleep.
But, these seven year
old kids are, you know,
they're not ready for that at all.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Anything else you'd like to get in to?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's heavy.
- You can edit that, I was just
giving you what I know man.
- [Interviewer] Yeah no, it's interesting.
So do you use drugs still?
- Yes I do.
I've done Suboxone for 10 years.
When I went to prison, I
started doing Suboxone.
When I got out of
prison, I kept doing them
because they really are like, you know,
they're exactly the same day as opiates.
But the thing about it is it
let me have control of my life.
Like I didn't have to
chase drugs every day.
I could do some of it and not
worry about drugs every day.
And then for the last two months,
I've felt I've went backwards.
And I've done heroin
for the last two months.
I had a house fire.
You know, there's no excuse for it,
but I've had a house fire and some thefts
from my business and my
house after it was on fire.
Everything that didn't burn was stolen.
And so I am using drugs.
I use heroin every day.
- [Interviewer] And are you married
or have kids or anything?
- I don't.
I'm not married and I don't have no kids.
- [Interviewer] You're still young,
so you can straighten your life out and.
- Yeah, you know, I do prefer
Suboxones over the heroin.
The only thing is is
you can't go from heroin
to Suboxone instantly.
Like I said, I've only
done it for two months.
In the first three or four weeks, I mean,
I was doing Suboxone and heroin.
And I actually done it
because I had a tooth ache,
so I done some heroin.
I had a agonizing tooth ache,
so I had done some hoping
it would make.
My mother actually gave
it to me, you know?
So that's another story.
But she actually offered it
to me and she's been on it.
She was down here, been
caught for trafficking
in Clay County multiple times.
- [Interviewer] Why do you think drugs
are so prevalent here in Appalachia?
Because I've been in
West Virginia many times,
and it's everywhere there as well.
- Yeah you know, there's
definitely a reason for that.
People want to, you know, escape.
This is a really simple
lifestyle down here.
You know, you can live
down here with no money.
Like people are really
good people down here.
As crazy as it is, a lot
of them are on drugs.
But if you're hitchhiking,
you can get a ride down here.
If you don't got nowhere to stay,
you can stay with your neighbor down here.
Like people, everybody knows everybody.
And it's like family down here, you know?
So, but the reason people are on drugs
is because they have
nothing else to turn to.
You know, everybody wants to feel good.
In the city, there's all
kinds of things you can go
to make you feel good.
You can go to the movies and
hang out with friends and.
Down here, you can't do that,
there's no movie theater.
There's no place for
kids other than church.
And like I said, if you're down here,
you might want to keep your kids out
of this church down here.
And drugs is like what everybody turns to.
And then, like I said, they
call this the "City of Hope."
I remember one time somebody
took some spray paint
and knocked off the H and put a D there.
And made it to say the
sign that coming in saying
the "City of Dope."
And drugs are worth a
lot more money down here
than they are in the city.
So with drugs being
worth a lot more money,
even in the city, I know people like, oh,
I'm buying all the drugs up
and I'm bringing them down here.
A lot of people transport
their drugs down here
because they are worth more money.
I'll tell you something else down here,
like even the police,
like I was talking about the government.
Were you familiar with any
of that before you came?
- [Interviewer] No.
- Like our mayor getting locked
up for being a sex offender
and he was sleeping with
like a 13 year old girl.
We had 18 more elected
officials arrested at one time.
And that's actually when my dad,
I told you my dad sold one pill.
That's actually why he ended
up getting arrested too,
caught up in the election fraud.
And he actually was one of the people
who couldn't get away from, that got away
from the election fraud.
And the feds don't like
to lose so they came back
and got him for anything they could.
He actually gave a pill to a
guy who had a camera on him,
and showed the guy good.
The guy said to my dad like
there was people out
acting crazy these days,
and my dad pulled out a gun and said,
let them act crazy around here.
You know, I got something for him.
And like I said, he gave the guy a pill
and the guy said his back was hurting.
And it wasn't no major pills,
it was a Lorsaid or something.
You know, like a 10 or $15 pill down here.
Very minor pill.
And so he wore the camera and the wire,
and they see my dad have the gun,
give the guy a pill, and also
snort a pill with the guy.
So they charged him with like
drug abuse by a gun owner
or something like that.
I guess, having a gun,
and even doing a drug
like where he snorted it.
What's that charge?
I can't remember the charge.
But he also got charged
with like a career criminal
because when he was 18 years old,
he hit a guy with an extinguisher
and stole a hundred dollars
from him and then got robbery.
And that was when I was born,
he was in the hospital for that.
I was actually conceived
in the jail down here.
My uncle was the jailer.
Before my dad went to prison,
my uncle let them go out
to this little picnic area.
And that's where I was conceived.
That's what my dad tells me
right before he went away.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right, Matthew.
Well thank you so much for
sharing your interesting story.
- [Matt] Yeah man.
- [Interviewer] Because I
don't want to get anybody
in trouble, but man, that's it.
- [Matt] Okay, I say we get
that guy in trouble man,
that might be another whole documentary
getting into something like that.
Like documenting, you know
that's a big topic right now
of sex offending, people with power.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Matt] Which nobody here has got
the kind of power that
you're talking about.